في الاستوديو نورنا اخصائي امراض العصبيه
دكتور خالد الصفار دكتور يسعد مساك اهلا
بك معنا في العربيه اهلا وسهلا طيب دكتور
هذا الشهر شهر ابريل هو الشهر التوعيه من
الضغط النفسي متى يكون التوتر حاله نفسيه
عاديه نتيجه ظروفنا اليوميه ومتى يتحول
الى حاله مرضيه تستدعي التدخل التوتر هو
هو اكثر من الضغط النفسي لان الضغط النفسي
هو مطلوب لكل عمل حتى يصير لي اتقان لكن
لما يزيد عن حتى يدخل مرحله التوتر ويؤدي
الى نتائج عكسيه نتائج عكسيه في اتقان
العمل نتائج عكسيه في العلاقات الاجتماعيه
نتائج عكسيه في علاقات العمل وفي كل مكان
واحد من يمشي بالشارع اذا عنده توتر زياده
ممكن ان تصدر منه يعني بعض الافعال اللي
هي غير مطلوبه يعني وغير طبيعيه يعني
دكتور خالد سنتحدث بواقعيه اليوم من منا
لا يعاني من توتر هل كتب علينا جميعا ان
نعيش مع هذه الحاله مكيف معها هو ظروف
العمل وظروف العالم كلها يعني تتطلب
التوتر العمل صار متعب صار معقد صار
بتنافس قوي الحصول على فرص العمل صعبه
المحافظه على العمل هي صعبه فهاي كلها
تخلي الانسان في توتر مستمر حتى يقدر
يحافظ بس بهالموضوع هو لازم يحاول ان يسوي
توازن بين ما انه يخرج عن الحد الطبيعي او
يستمر انه يحاول ان يوازن هذا الموضوع حتى
لا يخرج ولا يخسر دكتور استغل وجودك معانا
يعني هل تنصحنا ببعض التقنيات الممارسات
اليوميه للتخفيف اقل من التوتر وليس
التخلص منه البعض يراها في اليوغا التامل
في الرياضه في التنفس العميق بماذا تنصحني
كلها مطلوبه يعني اللي يقدر اللي عنده
مجال للوصول الى كل هذه اللي تفضلتي بهذا
ضروريه جدا لذلك ينصح بالرياضه بصوره
مستمره او يوميه بحاله يعني يجعلها
الانسان جزء من حياه اليوميه هذه جدا مهمه
لان في اي مرحله راح يدخل يعني يصير
التوتر لما يروح الى الرياضه راح يحس فرق
واضح وهذا احسن طريق يعني يفعل الانسان
حتى يتخلص من التوتر الرياضه اليوغا
التنفس العميق وممكن كلها يسويها في وقت
واحد يعني وقت معين اللي يوقا بالبيت
ويطلع للرياضه في وقت معين 20 دقيقه الى
نصف ساعه يوميا وهي ما تسوي شيء يعني ما
تاخذ شيء من الوقت فمهمه جدا للتخلص دكتور
خالد هل يمكن الحديث عن
تخفيف التوتر بالتغيير يعني مثلا تغيير
مكان العمل تغيير اصدقاء مثلا تجربه جديده
في الحياه
كل تغيير روتين هو مهم ومفيد بس تعتمد انه
هل الانسان عنده قابليه ان يغير العمل
يعني هل الانسان عنده قابليه ان يغير
الاصدقاء وبسرعه هو ان يكون ايجابي في اي
علاقه جديده في علاقات العمل علاقات العمل
تدري ان هي صعبه احنا يجونا مرضى عندهم
مشاكل بالعمل بس تنعكس تنعكس مثلا يصير
عنده داء شقيقه يعني صداع النصفي يصير
شديد جدا لان ما يروح العمل يتذكر العلاقه
لما يغير يعني احنا عندنا مرضى مثلا يسافر
شهر يرجع من السفر هو الموضوع اللي يعاني
منه بسبب الستريس راح همم اذا يرجع نفس
الظروف وتواجه نفس الضغوط راح يرجع ورا
اسبوعين ثلاثه تشوفين يرجع نفس
الضغوط ويرجع نفس الحاله فالتغيير مهم
طبعا
يعني متى يكون توتر خفيف يمكن نتعامل معه
بالممارسات يوميه اللي ذكرناها ومتى يتحول
الى حاله مرضيه خطيره تستدعي المساعده
الحاله المرضيه هو بس احنا نقدر نشخصها
يعني يعني الانسان دائما المرضى ما يعرفون
لان يجي مرات عنده حالات معينه من تشرح له
انه هاي قد تكون حاله نفسيه ولا يوجد عنده
مرض عضوي تحسه يزعل يعني لا انا ما عندي
شيء نفسي اني مطمئن اني مستقر اني عندي
مثلا راتبي كويس بس لما لما انت تقنعه
ويبدا بالعلاج تشوف ورا فتره يجي هو يكون
متشكر جدا الموضوع لان صعب كثير اعراب في
اعراض جسميه كان يكون عنده خدر نوع الصداع
قله النوم كلها بسبب توتر هو ما يعرف يعني
اتوقع انه هذا بس خالد بالعاده ما يذهب
مريض يعاني من وجع ما الم ما في جسده
غالبيه الاسئله من قبل الاطباء هل تعاني
من
توتر وخاصه نحن بشهر التوعيه بالتوتر
اليوم خصوصا مع كل هذه المسائل هل فعلا
التوتر والستريس يؤثر على اعضاءنا مثلا
ويزيد من الالم طبعا احنا كطباء حاليا
عندما نستقبل المريض بتكون علاقتنا
بايجابيه نسال كل التفاصيل لكن لما تكون
عندنا يعني ادله واضحه انه لا يوجد لا
يوجد هناك دلائل او ظواهر لمرض عضوي نبدي
نسال هذه الاسئله نعم فلما تبتي هاي
الاسئله في ناس كثير يعني مثلا يجي خدر
بايده وهذا دائما يروح علينا على اطباء
الاعصاب ما يروح على طبيب نفسي بالبدايه
لازم احنا نثبت له انه هذا يعني ما موجود
هذا على المرضيه مش مرض عضوي فتشوف بعد
ذلك راح تشوف فالتغير يعني اما يقسم ما
يقبلون وقسم نجبرهم يعني وبعدين العلاج
يصير سهل لما هو يقتنع ويتعاون ويانا
بالعلاج هو احنا في الاستوديو ونتمنى
السلامه للجميع طبعا شكرا جزيلا اخصائي
امراض العصبيه دكتور خالد الصفار شكرا
دكتور شكرا دكتور شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات